bonsoir alexis alors avec la séquence
sécurité de ce début de semaine peut-on
parler d'entrée en campagne officielle
presque pour emmanuel macron oui alors
on est habitué à l'hyperprésidence mais
c'est vrai que là on sent une sur
inflation de présence du président
partout il était sur le toit de notre
dame en ouvriers cordistes il était avec
les élèves de la quatrième c'est pas
loin pour comprendre que oui on pouvait
faire cours à distance ils étaient
pédopsychiatre et puis il était avec la
bac à montpellier pour dire que le
régalien c'est son affaire
il est partout tout le temps même sur
des chaînes étrangères a parlé en
anglais on le voit partout même si on
veut l'éviter et malades mal qu'on est
en campagne et ça se voit le problème c
est ce que ça peut marcher
on le voit avec ses syndicats policiers
qu'ils comprennent que c'est trop peu
trop tard que finalement l'autorité
n'est pas incarnée par ce jeune
président qui a eu du mal tout son
quinquennat à faire du régalien à faire
de la sécurité à faire finalement de la
république et donc ils s'empêtrent il se
prend les pieds dans le tapis
avec à la fois la sécurité en essayant
de faire du nicolas sarkozy mais très
mal un journal titrait le petit nicolas
on parlant d' emmanuel macron et puis de
faire aussi de la laïcité
et là encore cette marlène schiappa qui
est choisi pour parler de la laïcité et
qui marche sur des heures en essayant de
manier un concept qu'elle ne comprend
pas forcément à la hauteur de ce qu'il
est c'est à dire qu'il est
consubstantiel de la république
et là on trompe vraiment dans quelque
chose de grave parce que emmanuel macron
est en train de politiser absolument
tout pour essayer de pouvoir se
représenter avec un bilan qu'il ne peut
pas présenter face aux français parce
que de tous les costumes qu'ils
endossent je vous ai parlé de cette
déguisement qui sont nombreux il y en a
un qu'il ne veut pas mettre ces
monsieurs cent mille morts sa gestion de
la crise sanitaire est calamiteuse et là
il veut tout faire pour la faire oublier
effectivement elle est si vous parliez
tout d'abord on va prendre les choses
dans l'ordre la laïcité avec le
lancement de ce jour cette nouvelle
initiative vous lisiez de marlène
schiappa de quoi donner plus de gages
régaliens
oui exactement c'est ce que je disais et
on voit bien qu'ils cherchent les thèmes
où il va pouvoir prendre de la hauteur
redevenir président parce que à chaque
sortie à l'on a vu ces scènes où des
gens sans masque sans geste comptables
prennent des celle ci avec le président
mais on a aussi vu le hors champ où
beaucoup de personnes étaient là pour
lui et emmanuel macron pour le traiter
de tous les noms parfois avec beaucoup
d' insulte et donc il doit d'une
certaine façon se représidentialiser lui
qui a perdu beaucoup de terrain depuis
cette crise sanitaire on l'a traité
d'épidémiologistes on l'a traitée de
beaucoup de noms comme je le disais mais
il a montré finalement beaucoup de
communication est très peu d'efficacité
or ce qu'on attend d'un président c'est
un cap
c'est une organisation et c'est surtout
rassurer et protéger les français et on
al'impression qu'avec m l'alma coup non
seulement les français ne sont pas
protégés mais ils sont attaqués de
l'intérieur par une présidence
paranoïaque pris aux abois la preuve en
est c'est que depuis le 29 septembre
2020 le calendrier l'agenda de la
semaine du président n'est plus publié
n'est plus envoyé aux journalistes c'est
une surprise
chaque jour on attend de savoir où il va
apparaître et comment il va faire pour
juguler cette crise sanitaire
or sur la crise sanitaire et on le voit
on en parlera bien sûr tout de suite
dans cet édito il se prend là encore les
pieds dans le tapis et sur la laïcité
j'attends de voir ce qui sortira des
états généraux de marlène schiappa mais
on voit bien qu'il ya déjà là un axe
fort politique de donner des gages à une
certain certain électorat de droite pour
dire 'attendez 2022 ne sera pas sans moi
vous verrez que je veux pouvoir me
représenter mais rien n'est moins sûr
compte tenu justement de ce bilan
sanitaire est justement septembre à ce
bilan sanitaire et la stratégie mis à
mal est-ce que c'est clairement le plus
gros risque aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron oui alors lui fait tout pour le
minimiser pour le faire oublier pour
parler de tout sauf évidemment de
sanitaires et il demande du bleu
davantage de bleu dix mille policiers à
la fin de son quinquennat
leblanc on l'a oublié le rouge tous les
morts également on l'a oublié
or c'est le drapeau français et la
caisse qui fait et bien il est en train
de donner des bâtons pour se faire
battre avec ces dates
données pour le mois de mai pour la
réouverture en disant on la trame dia
coûte que coûte
y compris la réouverture des écoles même
si ça n'était relance ça ne tient pas et
là ça pourrait évidemment tout faire
capoter parce qu'on a vu déjà le
problème avec les vaccins
astrazeneca halle qui a été critiquée
johnson & johnson qui a été arrêté puis
relancé ses vaccins qui pose des
problèmes de santé on aimerait savoir
les français aimeraient savoir si le
bénéfice risque elle réellement en leur
faveur en fonction de la population à
laquelle ils appartiennent
et puis derrière l'idée que ce tunnel
n'en finit pas parce que variant brésil
certes
et puis maintenant le double mutants
indien qui viendrait par avion d'inde et
on entend clément bonin secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes dire que
oui peut-être qu'on prendra une décision
sur l'inde mais on verra parce que
évidemment avec l'un de ses plus
compliqué de manière diplomatique
on a des rapports de vente d'armes
notamment les rafales et d'autres choses
qui font qu'on ne peut pas couper les
vols aussi rapidement qu'on l'a fait
avec le brésil même si c'était très peu
rapide avec le brésil donc les variantes
sont en train de se répandre sur le
territoire national la france devient
une sorte de shaker à variant et là
c'est une question que posent certains
épidémiologistes 1 à des médias publics
en disant on se demande si aujourd'hui
la stratégie de l'exécutif c'est
vraiment de jubilé le virus ou bien
d'atteindre l'immunité de groupe à
n'importe quel prix au coin qu'il en
coûte or le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est beaucoup de vies c'est beaucoup de
souffrance et c'est pas les moyens
donnés aujourd'hui aux hôpitaux
or si emmanuel mac on veut se
représenter devant les français en 2022
il devra être celui qui aura réussi à
gérer cette crise sanitaire parce qu'il
s'est mis en avant depuis le début comme
l'épidémiologiste numéro un est là ce
qu'on voit c'est un échec flagrant de sa
politique depuis mars 2020 merci alexis
paulin d'avoir été avec moi